Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ihr habt alle schon darauf gewartet. Endlich geht es weiter mit der 2. Liga, hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Und ich hab mir dafür kompetente Hilfe geholt, mit Tim vom Millernton, jetzt im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Tim, ich freu mich sehr, dass du mit dabei bist.
Ja moin. Jetzt bin ich dir glatt in deinem Intro dazwischengegrätscht.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich hab mich so gefreut, dass ich endlich hier bin bei dir.
Ja, der Frühstarter, der Podcast Coitus interruptus. Ich hätte sogar rausgemuted, jetzt lass ich es drin. Weißt du was, das gönnen wir uns einfach. Tim, erklär unseren Hörern und Hörern, den zwei, die es noch nicht wissen, was ist der Millernton und was machst du da?
Genau, ich bin beim Millernton. Der Millernton ist ein Fan-Medium des FC St. Pauli. Wir machen eine ganze Menge, auch auf Podcastschiene. Also wir haben zwei Arten des Podcasts. Da haben wir einmal die Monatssendung, so nennen wir sie inzwischen, da machen wir ein paar größere Sachen. Wir haben auch einen guten Kontakt zum Verein, wo wir dann auch gerne mal ein paar Spieler oder Ewald Lin oder Andreas Rettig zu Gast hatten. Dann haben wir ein sehr schönes Format, bei dem ich seit Kurzem auch mitmache. Das ist vor dem Spiel, nach dem Spielgespräch, wo wir immer mit einem Fan des nächsten Gegners sprechen oder des letztmaligen Gegners. Und dann haben wir auch noch einen Blog dabei, da bin ich auch ein bisschen aktiv gerade und habe da hauptsächlich so einen Fokus auf taktische Fragen. Das FC St. Pauli, da passiert momentan eine ganze Menge. Oder wie soll ich sagen, da war eine ganze Menge los. Und da konnte ich mich schön auslassen in den letzten Wochen drüber.
Absolut. Und man kann bei diesem vor dem Spiel, nach dem Spiel unter anderem eine echte Perle hören, mit einem Heidenheim-Fan aus Übersee. Also, schwer genug, jemanden in Deutschland zu finden. Nein, das mögen mir die Heidenheim-Fans verzeihen. Aber allzu zahlreiche sind sie dann doch nicht, zumindest nicht in meinem Umfeld. Und ihr findet dann so egal, jemand von einem anderen Kontinent. Chapeau, Tim. Da war ich bitte einig.
Ja, da war ich auch sehr beeindruckt. Also, das war eine, ja, genau, eine Sarah aus Toronto in Kanada. Und die hat in der Nähe da studiert in Heidenheim irgendwie Romanistik und ist einfach mit Heidenheim also in love gewesen und das auch immer noch. Und die steht auch echt dann an 5.13 Uhr.
Ach, solche Geschichten, Tim, schreibt ausschließlich. Der Fußball. Und es gab auch viele Geschichten, die dieser 31. Spieltag geschrieben hat. Und entgegen des Sendungskonzeptes, was eigentlich geplant war für diese Folge, haben sich mal wieder die Erstligisten in den Vordergrund gedrängt. Und wir müssen jetzt doch noch kurz auch noch über den 1. FC Köln und den HSV sprechen. Warum müssen wir über Köln sprechen? Nun ja, die haben am Freitagabend zu Hause gegen Darmstadt 98 mit 1 zu 2 verloren, damit aus den letzten vier Spielen sage und schreibe zwei Punkte geholt und einen neuen Trainer. Markus Anfang ist weg. Und da frage ich dich, Tim, als jemand, der die zweite Liga schon etwas länger verfolgt, überrascht dich das, wenn ein Absteiger so sich verhält, so kurz vor Saisonende den Ausstieg ja immer noch relativ sicher in der Tasche?
Also ich muss erstmal eine Lanze für die zweite Liga brechen, weil wenn ich so diese Stimmen aus Köln und dann aus der Hamburger Vorstadt gehört habe, vor der Saison, ja, jetzt gehen wir mal runter in die zweite Liga, dann bauen wir alles neu zusammen und dann rocken wir die zweite Liga. Das war so im Grunde das Echo, was man gehört hat aus den beiden Regionen. Und das fand ich eigentlich, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, das fand ich ziemlich arrogant der zweiten Liga gegenüber. Und jetzt mit etwas Verspätung kann ich endlich sagen, vor allem in Richtung HSV kann ich sagen, hallo, herzlich willkommen in der zweiten Liga. Und ich gönne es, auch wenn ich nicht unbedingt viel mehr Sympathien für Paderborn und Union habe, aber ich gönne es dem HSV durchaus, dass er da stehen bleibt, wo er jetzt steht.
Ja gut, da spricht natürlich auch der St. Pauli-Fan. Ich hatte bei der Köln-Entlassung den Eindruck, dass die Trennlinie derjenigen Menschen, die diesen Schritt nachvollziehen konnten zu diesem Saisonzeitpunkt und derjenigen, die da drüber nur den Kopf schütteln konnten, ziemlich genau daran verlief, wie eng man sich mit diesem Verein befasst hat in den letzten Wochen. Diejenigen, die tiefer drin sind, haben das zum einen kommen sehen und fanden den Schritt eher überfällig. Diejenigen, die das nur so aus der Ferne beobachten, dachten sich, was ist denn da los? Also mit immer noch sechs Punkten Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz, bei noch neun zu vergebenden Spielen den Trainer zu entlassen, dessen Ziel der Aufstieg war – also der Aufstieg scheint ja erreicht werden zu können – das hat nicht ganz viel Sinn ergeben. Wo stehst denn du in diesen beiden Lagern?
Ich stehe auf der Seite der Kritiker, die gesagt haben, ja, das funktioniert da nicht mit Anfang in Köln. Der hat über die ganze Saison eigentlich einen recht kreativlosen Fußball spielen lassen. Und nachdem er letzte Saison mit Kiel ja tatsächlich auch einen tollen Fußball gespielt hat in der 2. Liga, hätte ich das persönlich ganz anders erwartet. Und mit dem 1. FC Köln in der 2. Liga spielen, mit dem Kader, da muss ich sagen, das ist auch so ein bisschen wie Cheaten beim Computerspiel. Wenn man da sich entscheiden kann zwischen Terode, Cordoba und Modest, das ist irgendwie – ich persönlich wundere mich nicht, dass Köln da die Reißleine gezogen hat. Ob das nun jetzt, dass man es vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher und ohne viel Tamtam hätte machen können nach Saisonende, das kann ich mir sicher auch vorstellen, aber es ist auch immer noch der 1. FC Köln, über den wir hier sprechen.
Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Also für den FC gibt es jetzt noch drei Spiele in Fürth, zu Hause gegen Regensburg und in Magdeburg. Da muss man dann einfach nur ein Drei erholen und dann wird das reichen. Für den HSV, da sieht die ganze Lage jetzt schon sehr viel kritischer aus. Man hat aus den letzten sechs Partien drei Niederlagen, drei Unentschieden. Und die Niederlage gegen Union jetzt am Spieltag hat besonders wehgetan, weil man damit aus den Aufstiegsrängen komplett rausgefallen ist. Aktuell Tabellenvierter. Die Sympathien haben wir ja schon geklärt. Tim, das ist ja auch leicht nachzuvollziehen. Und dennoch, wenn ich jetzt hier schon einen St. Pauli-Fan an der Strippe habe, es fällt ja durchaus auf. Es gab dieses für euch sehr schmerzhafte Derby mit dem 4 zu 0 auf St. Pauli. Und danach lief nichts mehr beim HSV. Was habt ihr mit denen gemacht, dass die daran gebrochen sind an einem 4 zu 0-Sieg?
Das ist tatsächlich der Derby-Flug, den der FC St. Pauli auch ereilt hat, als St. Pauli damals in der Erstliga-Saison den HSV geschlagen hat. Die haben nämlich den HSV geschlagen, das war am 16. Februar. Und ab da haben sie dann, ich glaube, noch einen Punkt in Wolfsburg geholt, aber sonst alles verloren und sind sang und klanglos abgestiegen. Ich lege mich jetzt fest, das ist ein Fluch, also der Derby-Fluch.
Ja, verrückt, hätte man das mal vorher gewusst. Aber gut, dann bleibt eventuell der HSV sogar der 2. Liga noch erhalten. Mal gucken, was da jetzt aus den letzten Spielen zu Hause gegen Ingolstadt in Paderborn und zu Hause gegen den MSV Duisburg noch herunterfällt. Paderborn, die haben mit einem 3 zu 1 gegen Heidenheim sich auf den 2. Platz geschoben, Union Berlin durch den Zug. Sieg gegen den HSV, jetzt gerade auf dem Relegationsplatz Nummer 3. Es ist also sehr eng geblieben an diesem 31. Spieltag. Und es gab auch mal wieder etwas für dich zu feiern. Denn St. Pauli hat 4 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Regensburg gewonnen. In einem Spiel, in dem es zwar um die buchstäbliche goldene Ananas ging, wurde ja auch so verarbeitet in der Fankoreografie. Wie wichtig war denn aus deiner Sicht dennoch jetzt diese Partie und dass man mal wieder ein Dreier geholt hat?
Also für die Grundstimmung am Millernton war das schon mal überfällig, dass das passiert. Man muss dazu sagen, dass jetzt mit Lukaj ein neuer Trainer gekommen ist, aber der in den ersten zwei Spielen dann der Mannschaft den Teufel dann irgendwie nicht austreiben konnte. Ja, jein. Also am Anfang hat er sich gegen Bielefeld ein sehr offensives Pressing versucht, auch zu Hause ein Angriffspressing spielen, hat er sich womöglich gedacht, das ist eine gute Option, allerdings hast du mit Alex Maier und Sami Alagi da vorne jetzt nicht die Formel-1-Ränner, die nicht unbedingt für ein hohes Angriffspressing irgendwie, naja, zumindest geeignet schienen und dementsprechend lief das gegen Bielefeld auch gar nicht so gut, erst als dann in der Halbzeit ein bisschen umgestellt wurde auf ein klares 4-1-4-1, wurde das ein bisschen besser. Dieses 4-1-4-1 ist tatsächlich was, was auch unter Kauchinski ganz am Anfang der Saison gespielt wurde. Da war man übrigens Tabellenführer nach zwei Spieltagen. Als es dann nicht lief, wurde es auf so ein, naja, das altbewährte Rezept auf St. Pauli heißt 4-2-3-1 und ein kompaktes 4-4-2 im Mittelfeldpressing und dann werden wir das schon irgendwie umschalten können und dann das irgendwie schaffen. Da wurde dann auch immer gern darauf zurückgegriffen, wenn es mal nicht lief. Bisher ist das unter Luhlkein noch nicht passiert. Gegen Regensburg hat man dann, ja, gegen Regensburg ist das völlige Chaos auf dem Platz entstanden. Das lag aber nicht unbedingt nur an dem FC St. Pauli oder an der schlechten Formation oder zum einen war die Einstellung bei St. Pauli eine ganz andere als in den Spielen davor. Also, die sind richtig draufgegangen. Zum anderen hat Regensburg auch überhaupt kein Interesse daran, dass irgendwer irgendwas geordnetes macht auf dem Spielfeld. Das war dann aber tatsächlich – ich habe mich jetzt inzwischen festgelegt – das war dann eine Dreierkette, die St. Pauli gespielt hat, die man aber auch nicht viel gesehen hat. Ich will jetzt nicht zu tief ins Detail gehen, aber da war viel Mannorientierung. Da haben sich viele verschiedene Sachen ergeben. Aber das war auf jeden Fall so ein Brustlöser, der mal dringend nötig war am Millerntor hier bei uns.
20 zu 9 Abschlüsse, 10 zu 3 Torschüsse, was unter anderem auch aussagt, dass Jan Regensburg an dem Tag auch wirklich gutes Zielwasser getrunken hatte. Jeder Schuss aufs Tor, der saß dann auch tatsächlich. Es ist insofern ja wichtig für die Stimmung des FC St. Pauli, weil die Rückrunde so lief, wie sie lief. Also am Ende der Hinserie Platz 4, Punktgleich mit Union Berlin auf Platz 3. Das heißt, alle Chancen auf den Ausstieg. Und jetzt gucken wir auf die Rückrundentabelle und sehen, der Trost ist, dass auf Platz 14 der HSV liegt. Das Schmerzhafte ist, in der FC St. Pauli liegt nur ein Plätzchen und ein Pünktchen darüber, nämlich auf Platz 13 der Rückrundentabelle. Was ist denn da schiefgelaufen im System St. Pauli, dass man so eingebrochen ist?
Ich würde fast sagen, schiefgelaufen ist die zu gute Hinrunde. Also da hat die Mannschaft sehr viele gute Ergebnisse eingefahren, ohne aber wirklich nachhaltig guten Fußball zu spielen. Und damit sind einfach Erwartungen gestiegen, die die Mannschaft nicht halten konnte. Dann sind da auch eigene Erwartungen gewesen, vor allem nachdem man dann Ingolstadt und Paderborn geschlagen hat und dann das Derby vor der Brust hatte. Und eigentlich, naja, mit dem Derby-Sieg wäre man auf Platz 2 fest gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und da wurden dann Erwartungen geschürt an allen Ecken und Enden. Ich glaube, das ist dann auch so ein bisschen dann, naja, Markus Koczynski am Ende so ein bisschen zum Verhängnis geworden, dass dann man eigentlich dachte, das Team ist besser, als es letztendlich ist. Also ich persönlich habe den FC St. Pauli auch nie als Spitzenteam gesehen. Trotzdem will ich auf jeden Fall, dass die aufsteigen. Ich will es auch immer noch. Aber ich glaube, die Mannschaft hat über ihre Verhältnisse gespielt in der Hinrunde und bessere Ergebnisse eingefahren, als die Spiele letztendlich waren. Das hat in der Rückrunde ganz schön Knick gegeben, als man die Spiele, die man knapp glücklich gewonnen hat in der Hinrunde, eben mal verloren hat. Dann stimmte anscheinend auch ein bisschen der Charakter in der Truppe nicht. Dann ging es relativ schnell abwärts und war jetzt auch schwer da, oder ist immer mit Sicherheit noch ein schwerer Weg, da wieder rauszukommen.
Und wie bewertest du dann den Trainerwechsel, also Koczynski weg, Józ Luhokaj dafür auf die Trainerbank?
Ich persönlich muss ehrlich gestehen, dass ich jetzt von Luhokaj, dass ich da nicht, nachdem er Trainer geworden ist, nicht sofort mitbekommen habe, dass er sich nachhaltig empfohlen hat dafür, dass er jetzt radikale Fußballkonzepte entwickelt hat. Aber vielleicht ist so ein knurriger Holländer gar nicht so schlecht für die Mannschaft an sich, für das Team an sich. Ich hätte mir natürlich gewünscht, aber das wünscht sich wahrscheinlich jeder Zweitelige ist jetzt, dass jemand wie Tim Walther um die Ecke kommt, der bei Holstein Kiel einfach mutigen Fußball spielen lässt, super radikales Konzept entwickelt hat. Dass das nicht unbedingt zwingend möglich ist und solche Trainer nicht überall an jeder Ecke stehen, ist mir auch klar.
Und der Weg von Kiel nach Hamburg zu St. Pauli ist natürlich auch zwar ein kurzer, aber nicht ganz o-problematischer. Oder hätte man in dem Fall dann ein Auge zugedrückt?
Also wir auf St. Pauli drücken sowieso ein Auge zu, weil das Nordderby, was da konzipiert wird, das gibt es nur auf Kieler Seite. St. Pauli gegen Kiel. Aber ja, ich denke, Tim Walther hat sich da eher für noch höhere Aufgaben empfohlen. Und mitten in der Saison wäre er sowieso nicht gewechselt. Die Situation war bei St. Pauli einfach so, dass es anscheinend auch in dem Moment nicht mehr ging, dass da was was herhalten musste. Eventuell auch mit ein bisschen Weitsicht, dass es jetzt so ist, dass Juss Luu Kai auch einfach die Mannschaft schon mal kennenlernen kann und dann in der neuen Saison ein bisschen neuer Sprung geholt werden sollte. Da wurde zwar am Anfang gesagt, wir wollen nochmal oben angreifen, blablabla, aber eigentlich war der Zug schon so ein bisschen abgefahren. Wenn man sich jetzt die Ergebnisse anguckt, dann ärgert man sich doch schon ganz schön, wie wenig Punkte man jetzt bisher aus den letzten 8 Spielen oder so geholt hat, weil die anderen Teams, die haben sich ja auch nicht mit Ruhmbekleider bekleckert. Und wenn ich mir angucke, dass Union Berlin jetzt mal wieder gewonnen hat gegen den HSV, die haben ja auch länger dann nicht mehr gewonnen. Jetzt sind die auf einmal auf dem dritten und St. Pauli ist mit fünf Punkte dahinter, da hätte ein Pobeliga-Sieg gereicht und man wäre mittendrin im Rennen.
Aber das stellt ja schon ganz gut so ein bisschen die mittelfristige Frage nach der Perspektive des FC St. Pauli. Du hast vorhin gesagt, du willst aufsteigen, das ist jetzt wenig überraschend. Der Verein würde auch gerne aufsteigen, das ist auch völlig klar. Und trotzdem stelle ich mir jetzt schon länger die Frage, ich höre ja auch immer wieder beim Millernton rein, welche Rolle spielt denn eigentlich St. Pauli in der zweiten Liga? Und ist die zweite Liga so aufgestellt, dass man wirklich mit einem Aufstieg als eine Mannschaft wie St. Pauli mit den Strukturen rechnen kann? Oder gehört nicht St. Pauli einfach zu dieser Regel von vielleicht acht, vielleicht sogar neun, zehn Mannschaften in der zweiten Liga, die sehr solide Grundstrukturen haben und deswegen in der Regel es immer schaffen sollten, nicht zu weit nach unten zu rutschen in der Tabelle? Und dann kann mal ein Aufstieg dabei vom Laster fallen quasi, aber dafür müssen halt viele Dinge zusammenkommen. Wie siehst du es? Das ist jetzt so meine externe Sicht.
Ja, bei St. Pauli muss man ja inzwischen sagen, dass die auch von der finanziellen Seite, die haben uns, glaube ich, fünf oder sechs Jahre in Folge Gewinne geschrieben, dass St. Pauli nicht mehr das ist, was sie vor zehn Jahren gewesen sind, nämlich so ein Chaos-Pleiten-Club, sondern es ist inzwischen ein absolut solide geführter Verein, der auf vielen Ebenen führend ist in der zweiten Liga und dementsprechend auch anderen Teams voraus ist.
Und sind das auch sportliche Ebenen oder sind das nur so Ebenen, also was heißt nur, aber sind das solche Ebenen, vor allem wie Merchandising zum Beispiel, also eben die Kosten- und Finanzierungsstruktur, die man hat, Zuschauereinnahmen oder geht es auch da um sportliche Dinge?
Ja, das Sportliche hängt da so ein bisschen hinterher. Das hast du jetzt den Finger sehr schön in die Wunde gelegt auf jeden Fall. Sportlich werden die Ziele oder würde ich fast behaupten, dass der Kader da ein bisschen Federn gelassen hat und auch auf lange Sicht oder auch im Sommer müsste da was passieren im Kader, weil die besten vermeintlichen Spieler auch weggehen mit Dudziak, der ja vielleicht, naja, dem ja so ein bisschen ein Schlendrian vorgeworfen wird, aber der, wenn man der möchte und fit ist, der echt einer der die absolute Säule eigentlich ist im Mittelfeld sein kann, dann hat man Richie Neudegger, der ja auch zwar eigentlich nicht so, nicht die Rolle spielt in der Rückrunde, aber eigentlich auch ein sehr guter Fußballer ist, der ja auch noch enormes Entwicklungspotenzial hat. Da wurde irgendwie verpasst, da richtig hinten nachzulegen. Da drückt von unten momentan nicht ganz so viel hoch, auch wenn mit Finn Olebecker jetzt aus der U19 einer hochkommt. Aber grundsätzlich ist beim FC St. Pauli so, dass gerade aus sportlicher Sicht so ein bisschen die Diskussion darüber lauft, was will man eigentlich und mit was will man eigentlich, ist eher die Frage, was für einen Fußball wollen wir eigentlich spielen? Was haben wir eigentlich für eine Grundidee von Fußball? Das ist so ein bisschen die Frage, die man sich gerade stellt. Der FC St. Pauli stand ganz lange für dieses Kämpfen, Beißen, Rennen. Das ist inzwischen fast, würde ich sagen, eine Grundtugend, die jedes Team hat. Jetzt müsste man eigentlich noch einen Schritt weitergehen und eine einheitliche oder eine Philosophie entwickeln, die einen auch abhebt von anderen 2. Liga-Teams. Was du auch gesagt hast, es gibt so einen Pool von 8 bis 10 Teams, die sich solide in der 2. Liga halten. Aber da muss man auch dazu sagen, dass es auch viele Teams gibt, die dann aus Versehen doch mal absteigen. Schau dir Braunschweig an, letzte Saison. Da war das überhaupt nicht vorgesehen. Da war es auch von der Kaderqualität nicht erfolgt. Und nun hatten wir eine Saison, wo mit Köln und HSV zwei Teams runtergegangen sind, bei denen klar war, die werden mindestens ein gehöriges Mörtchen mitreden um den Aufstieg. Klar, allein von den millionenteuren Kader, die beide haben. Nächste Saison in Nürnberg und Hannover vielleicht runtergehen, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das so ist. Und das ist vielleicht ein Moment, in dem man als so ein ambitioniertes 2. Liga-Team, was zwar nicht vom Kader her so die supergroßen Investitionen tätigen kann, aber das ist jetzt so eine Situation, wo man vielleicht mal ein bisschen was riskieren sollte für die nächste Saison.
Ja, stimmt. Da hast du natürlich recht. Das könnte dann wieder ein anderes Jahr werden. Vielleicht war ich da auch wirklich noch so ein bisschen geprimed. Vorher war ja mit Stuttgart jetzt auch nicht so der kleinste Verein der 1. Liga dann in der 2. Liga vertreten. Das stimmt natürlich. Da hat sich ein bisschen was getan. Aber das soll ja auch so ein bisschen das Überthema dieser Folge sein. Und zwar nicht nur beim FC St. Pauli, sondern wir haben in der letzten Folge uns die Spitze der Liga angeguckt und das Ende der Liga. Jetzt wollen wir mal so ein bisschen das aktuelle Tabellen im Mittelfeld durchgehen. Und wenn wir schon vorhin über Regensburg kurz gesprochen haben, dann lass uns da doch noch mal ein kleines bisschen tiefer reingehen. Du hast sie jetzt gerade erlebt beim 4 zu 3 Erfolg der St. Paulianer am Wochenende. Was ist denn der Jan für eine Mannschaft deiner Meinung nach?
Jan Regensburg ist, ich glaube, eine der unangenehmsten Mannschaften der 2. Liga zu spielen für alle Teams. Ich winke dann auch mal rüber in die Hamburger Vorstadt. Die haben nämlich zu Hause 5-0 verloren gegen Regensburg, wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
War das nicht sogar eines der allerersten Spiele der Saison?
Genau, das war relativ zu Beginn der Saison, 5. oder 6. Spieltag, wenn ich mich festlegen müsste.
23.
Ja, genau. Regensburg ist auf jeden Fall ein Team, das keine Interesse daran hat, wirklich Fußball oder Ballbesitz-Fußball zu spielen, weder bei SIG noch beim Gegner. Wenn man sich die Quoten von ihnen anguckt, dann sieht man, dass sie mit Abstand die wenigsten Pässe in der 2. Liga spielen, die schlechteste Passquote haben in der 2. Liga, was eher ein Zeichen dafür ist, dass sie die wenigen Pässe, die sie dann spielen, eigentlich strikt vertikal spielen, mit hohem Risiko, aber nicht sonderlich viel aufbauen. Dann führen sie die meisten Zweikämpfe in der 2. Liga. Das spricht eigentlich Bände. Ich halte zwar nicht so viel von solchen einfachen Statistiken, aber wenn man das mal kombiniert und die auch gesehen hat, dann weiß man eigentlich ziemlich genau, was das für eine Truppe ist, nämlich eine, die einfach viel über den Kampf kommt und viel Chaos, Unruhe auf den Platz stiften will. Und dazu haben sie dann noch mit Adam Jan da auf der linken Außenseite einen richtig, richtig guten Fußballer, der allein am Wochenende gegen St. Pauli durch zwei wahnsinnig gute Tempoläufe über die linke Seite zwei Tore eingeleitet hat.
Würdest du sagen, dass Jan Regensburg mit all den Eigenschaften, die du da beschrieben hast, dann ein besonderes Team in der 2. Liga ist, also heben die sich dadurch ab?
Inzwischen ja, also eine Zeit lang war es nicht so. Eine Zeit lang, es gab so bis vor, eigentlich seit dieser Saison erst, gibt es wieder so den Trend, dass viele Teams auch versuchen, Ballbesitzfußball zu spielen. Jahrelang war die 2. Liga eine reine Umschaltliga, in der es einfach in pure Fehlervermeidung ging, in der einfach, ich würde sagen, die blanke Angst herrschte. Ich möchte an der Stelle, es ist ganz gut, dass Mario Gomez in der 1. Liga diesen Angsthasenfußball verurteilt hat. Er hat gesagt, dass es kein Qualitätsmerkmal ist, dass in der 1. Liga alles noch so eng zusammen ist kurz vor Schluss. Ich möchte daran erinnern, dass in der 2. Liga zwischen Platz 4 und Platz 17 drei Spieltage vor Schluss waren. Das waren nur 5 oder 6 Punkte. Wenn man das allein punktetechnisch betrachtet und das auf die Qualität oder auf die unterschiedlichen Qualitäten bringt, dann kann man schon sagen, da hat sich was getan. Aber die 2. Liga war auf jeden Fall so eine Liga, in der Teams wie Regensburg keine Besonderheit waren. Inzwischen ist es allerdings ein bisschen anders.
Und wie sortiert sich dann z. B jemand wie Amina Bielefeld da ein? Wenn ich von außen draufschaue, dann ist es zum einen so, dass die Amina für mich schon immer zur 2. Liga dazugehört hat. Da blende ich dann, glaube ich, auch einige Jahre einfach wohlwollend aus, weil kann ich mir erlauben, ich habe keine emotionale Bindung zu diesem Verein. Und wenn ich jetzt einfach nur so draufgucke, dann sind die für mich das Mittelmaß der 2. Liga. 10 Siege, 10 Unentschieden, 11 Niederlagen, 46 geschossene Tore, 50 kassierte Tore, 40 Punkte, aktuell Platz 9.
Das ist dieses Jahr tatsächlich der VfL Bochum, da kommen wir gleich noch dazu. Bielefeld hat auf jeden Fall einen bewegten Saisonverlauf, die sind mega schlecht gestartet, haben sich dann von ihrem Trainer auch getrennt und haben jetzt inzwischen den Status erreicht. Die haben sich Uwe Neuhaus geholt, der vorher Trainer in Dresden war, zu Anfang der Saison noch. Und Uwe Neuhaus ist dafür bekannt, das ist ein Trainer, der lässt Fußball spielen. Der hat Bock auf Ballbesitzfußball. Und Bielefeld war auch vor drei Wochen am Millerntor. Da hatte ich erzählt, St. Pauli hat gerne beim Angriffspressing gespielt. Die haben stumpf über Ortega, der ein sehr guter Fußballer ist, der Torwart der Bielefelder. Da haben die einfach ihren Sattel runtergespielt und einfach flach aufgebaut. Die haben es einfach immer wieder gemacht, egal wie hoch das Risiko war. Finde ich persönlich toll, finde ich mutig. Und die spielen eine sehr gute Rückrunde. Beziehungsweise seit Neuhaus da spielen sie einen sehr guten Fußball an sich. Haben davor einen absolut grausig gespielt. Da unter Neuhaus hat sich das inzwischen zu so einem 4-3-3 rauskristallisiert. Ich glaube, je älter er wird, desto besser Fabian Kloss ist inzwischen für mich fast der beste Stürmer der 2. Liga. Er spielt eine wahnsinnig gute Rückrunde. Ist übrigens auch – ich weiß nicht, kennst du den Goal-Impact? Danach ist er der beste Spieler der 2. Liga.
Ach krass.
War es vor zwei Jahren zumindest. In der Winterpause haben sie sich mit Reinhold Jaberow verstärkt, der ja auch beim KSZ fast aufgestiegen ist und dann Richtung Salzburg gegangen ist. Einfach ein spielstarker, zentraler Mittelfeldspieler. Und die haben nach Köln und Paderborn 2019 tatsächlich die meisten Tore geschossen. Da ist auf jeden Fall Fußball vorhanden.
Also in der Rückrundentabelle liegt die Armenia auf Tabellenplatz 6 hin. In der Tabellenplatz-6-Hinserie war es Tabellenplatz 14. Den Switch hast du da ja ganz gut beschrieben. Wenn ich jetzt Bielefeld mal mit St. Pauli vergleichen würde, wo würdest du denn da jetzt auch von den Strukturen des Vereins her die Unterschiede sehen?
Ja, also zum einen würde ich jetzt sagen, dass Bielefeld im Grunde fast ein oder zwei Schritte hinter St. Pauli war. Der Verein hat sich finanziell, hat er sich, ich glaube, in der Winterpause urplötzlich gesundet. Es war eigentlich eher so ein Pleiten-Club, der wahnsinnige finanzielle Probleme hatte. Hat es dann, glaube ich, über so ein Konsortium von ostwestfälischen Unternehmern, haben die das geschafft, den Verein mit einmal schuldenfrei zu machen. Und damit hat sich die ganze wirtschaftliche Situation bei dem Club natürlich auch komplett geändert inzwischen. Und ich glaube, dass wenn da im Sommer gute Entscheidungen getroffen werden, dann ist Bielefeld mit Bochum und St. Pauli sicherlich einer der Clubs, die mit nach oben wollen oder Ansprüche anmelden können.
Das ist ja tatsächlich eine interessante Entwicklung, die völlig an mir vorbei gegangen ist, dass tatsächlich Arminia seine Schulden losgeworden ist. Am 17.01. titelte Kicker.de mit Arminia Bielefeld nahezu schuldenfrei. Und es waren alle DFL-Auflagen, die aufgrund von mindestens 22, 4 Millionen Euro Verbindlichkeiten erst auf der Kippe standen, in nur einem Treffen von vielen privaten Gläubigern und einer Investmentgruppe bereinigt. So kann es also auch gehen in der 2. Liga. Ist es dann auch nachhaltig?
Das weiß ich nicht. Dazu bin ich tatsächlich zu wenig drin in Bielefeld. Ich hoffe für so ein Club natürlich, dass es nachhaltig ist. Auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich viele Sympathien für Bielefeld hege, da die Bielefelder Fans gerne sich mit den HSV ganz gut versteht. Deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht so die Sympathien für Bielefeld. Ist mir allerdings immer noch lieber als ein Plastik-Club, der da herkommt. Aber das ist dann eine andere Kiste. Ich weiß nicht, wie nachhaltig das ist. Ich glaube auf jeden Fall, dass mit Uwe Neuhaus da ein Trainer ist, der ganz ansehend im Fußball spielen lässt, was ja im Grunde immer schon mal eine schöne Sache ist. Und dementsprechend glaube ich, dass das Trainerleben von so einem Trainer, der ja ganz gerne mal schön Fußball spielt, das ist an sich so ein bisschen länger als zum Beispiel das von Markus Kowczynski gewesen ist, der ja eher, naja, immer eher auf Sicherheit bedacht war und eben weniger Fußball hat spielen lassen am Millerntor.
Ich meine, in Bielefeld ist man natürlich auch erstmal froh, dass man jetzt in der Saison aus der schwierigen Situation sehr gut rausgekommen ist. Allein in den letzten sechs Spielen, zwei Siege, drei Unentschieden, nur eine Niederlage. Das ist quasi stabil genug, dass man unten nicht reinrutscht, wo wir ja auch gerade sehen, anders als – na gut – mit Ausnahme des letzten Spieltags in der ersten Liga. Passiert da ja tatsächlich in der zweiten Liga noch was. Also da wird schon häufiger gewonnen von den Teams unten drin, gerade Ingolstadt mit drei Siegen aus den letzten vier Spielen. Da ist man, glaube ich, dann auch erstmal sehr froh, wenn man damit nichts zu tun hat. Und dann kann man ja unter den Voraussetzungen dann auch auf die nächste Saison hin planen. Als Nächstes in der Tabelle auf Tabellenplatz 10 begegnen wir dann Darmstadt 98, die jetzt mit diesem 2 zu 1 beim HSV den Klassenerhalt gesichert haben. Beim 1. FC Köln, Entschuldigung. Beim HSV haben zwar auch schon viele gewonnen, aber diesmal war es der 1. FC Köln. Da habe ich falsch zugeordnet. Darmstadt 98 ist ja auch ein ganz interessanter Verein, nicht nur wegen des zwischenzeitlichen Durchmarsches in die 1. Liga, sondern weil da ja auch so ein bisschen die Verwandlung eines unterklassigen Vereins zu einem mindestens Zweitligisten steht, wo alle Strukturen jetzt so ein bisschen nachziehen müssen. Also das berühmte Stadion am Böllnfalltor mit den ganz schlimmen Kabinen und jetzt mit der Frage, wie kann das jetzt renoviert werden, was ist da von der DFL dann an Auflagen zu erfüllen und so weiter und so fort. Das finde ich ist ein interessanter Verein, weil davon gibt es ein paar in der 2. Liga, die so an der Schwelle stehen. Sie müssen sich professionalisieren in ganz vielen ihrer Strukturen, aber sie müssen das halt immer mit dem entsprechenden Maß machen, dass man sich nicht verhebt, weil der Theorie nach ist ein Abstieg immer drin und von der 2. in die 3. Liga fällst du sehr hart. Würdest du bei der Einschätzung mitgehen?
Absolut. Also das nächste Beispiel, das wurde zwar letztes Mal schon besprochen, Holstein Kiel, ist so ein Verein, der massiv Probleme hat, da mitzuziehen bei der Entwicklung, das aber natürlich auch nicht überreizen will, weil es kann halt nächstes Jahr auch genauso wieder runtergehen. Also es ist schon schwierig. Darmstadt 98 ist tatsächlich für die 2. Liga ein, ja ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das Fluch oder Segen nennen möchte. Ich habe mich vor allem in meinen in meinen Taktik-Blogs, die ich gerne schreibe, habe ich mich jahrelang, habe ich mich wirklich abgearbeitet an Darmstadt, weil diesen diesen Fußball, weil ich fast behaupten möchte, dieser Fußball, den sie damals gespielt haben, mit dem sie auch aufgestiegen sind, da mit lange Bälle, lange Bälle, zweite Bälle über Sandro Wagner und über Dominik Stroh Engel war das damals. Da haben sie einfach den Fußball in der 2. Liga verseucht und einfach ganz viel, ganz viel kaputt gemacht und darauf fußt auf diesen Erfolg, den sie hatten, es gibt ihm ja tatsächlich recht, dieser Erfolg, den sie damals hatten, haben sich ganz viele 2. Liga-Teams eben dahin entwickelt, dass sie sagten, okay, wir schaffen das nicht, unseren Ballbesitz, Fußball, den wir spielen, mal so durchzubringen, dieses lange Ball, zweite Ball und dann darauf pressen, massiv pressen, das ist einfach eine Variante, die Defensiv-Fußball als leichter einzustudieren als Offensiv-Fußball, das ziehen wir jetzt durch und damit sieht man ja, wie erfolgreich der andere von einem gewesen ist. Deswegen habe ich ganz, ganz lange stand ich mit Namen statt 98 auf dem Kriegsfuß und habe auch immer noch im Nachhinein, obwohl die inzwischen schon wirklich Fußball spielen, habe ich immer noch gepestet gegen die ohne Ende und immer das Haar an der Suppe gesucht, weil ich persönlich sagen musste, dass die nachhaltig die 2. Liga verseucht haben und sich dann verpisst haben in die 1.
Und wie ist es jetzt unter Dimitrios Gramotsis, der ja eine sensationelle Bilanz hat. Nur zwei Niederlagen in seinen bisherigen acht Spielen als Darmstadt 98-Trainer, zwei Niederlagen, zwei unentschieden, der Rest wurde gewonnen.
Genau. Inzwischen ist es tatsächlich, also dann ist Dick Schuster ja Anfang der Saison ist er auch noch Trainer gewesen, ist in der letzten Saison übrigens auch eines der Teams gewesen, die sich nur ganz, ganz knapp gerettet haben vor dem Abstieg in die 3. Da haben wir wieder das Thema, dass man sich professionalisieren muss, aber wenn die in die 3. Liga runtergegangen wären, dann hätte das vielleicht auch ganz schnell zu Ende sein können. Aber die haben zu Beginn der Saison, haben die unter Schuster, haben die eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht einen Ball gespielt, hatten dann, ich glaube nach dem ersten Saison-Drittel hatten die oder nach dem ersten Viertel hatten die mit Abstand die meisten Pässe im offensiven Drittel gespielt, also tatsächlich auch aktiv dann vorne noch versucht Fußball zu spielen. Dann ist aber unter Schuster, das habe ich nicht so genau verfolgt, ist irgendwie der Flow da verloren gegangen und dann ist Gramozos gekommen und allgemein muss man aber sagen, dass da dann der Unterschied vielleicht gar nicht so groß ist zu dem, was sie früher gespielt haben, weil inzwischen haben die auch wieder heller auf der Außenbahn und sie haben mit dem Zoom einen ziemlich großen Spieler vorne, der da der Turm in der Schlacht ist. Was auffällig ist bei Darmstadt ist, da möchte ich das alte Sprichwort bedienen, dass die in den Hinten kackt die Kuh. Die haben tatsächlich, es sind Platz 18 nach Toren in den ersten 15 Minuten, die sie geschossen haben, aber haben dann in der letzten Viertelstunde die zweitmeisten Tore aller Teams geschossen. Also die sind auf jeden Fall, zumindest konditionell, können die alles mitgehen in der 2. Liga. Haben den FC St. Pauli auch kurz nach der Rückrunde durch zwei späte Tore besiegt.
Okay, das heißt, das sieht für diese Saison gerade jetzt stabil aus in leicht fremdem Gewande. Also wenn gewisse Dinge noch wieder zu erkennen, zum Teil ja in Spielerpersonalien selbst, dann ist das noch nicht ganz ein neues Darmstadt, aber ein bisschen hat sich's verändert. Dann kann man ja gucken, wie das in der nächsten Saison dann ablaufen wird. Und damit kommen wir dann endlich zur grauen Maus, die du vorhin so tituliert hast, zum VfL Bochum, der gefühlt jetzt schon seit Jahrzehnten, stimmt natürlich nicht ganz so, in der 2. Liga sich hält, selten, zumindest so wie ich es wahrgenommen habe, so richtig in hoher Gefahr schwebte, aber auch man sich sicher sein konnte, wenn die mal oben mit drin hängen, dann werden die schon irgendwann aus eigener Kraft wieder sich ins Mittelfeld verabschieden. Also irgendwas fehlt da immer beim VfL. Natürlich manchmal so Leute wie Leon Goretzka, die dann einfach weggekauft werden. Aber was wäre denn deine Diagnose? Warum schafft es Bochum nicht, wenigstens eine bunte Maus im Mittelfeld zu sein?
Ja, das ist dann so die Frage, was den Vereinsoberen dann vielleicht auch lieber ist. Ist man lieber so wie Bielefeld, dass man eine richtig schlechte Hinterrunde spielt, den Trainer wechselt und dann eine super Rückrunde spielt und dann irgendwo ähnlich da landet oder so, wie Darmstadt ein richtiges Zwischentief hat. Bei Bochum ist es tatsächlich so, dass die eigentlich schon die ganze Saison da irgendwie, ich würde mal jetzt sagen zwischen Platz 6 und Platz 13 irgendwie rumdimpeln. Die hatten zu Beginn der Rückrunde, haben sie mal kurz Richtung oben angeklopft, dann aber dann doch wieder ein paar Spiele auch nicht so gut gespielt und sind dann wieder runter. Die spielen eigentlich einen ganz guten Ball. Die spielen auch einen guten Ballbesitzfußball. Da hat sich unter Robin Durth so ein 4-2-3-1 manifestiert eigentlich. Sie sind sehr dominant, spielen sehr viele Pässe, haben fast die höchste Beibesitzquote aller Teams in der 2. Liga.
Ja, also auf Platz 5, aber mit weitem Abstand von vielen anderen Vereinen, die um sie herum in der Tabelle liegen.
Genau, und dann haben sie jetzt endlich, sie schlagen die meisten Flanken in der Liga, habe ich vorhin irgendwo gelesen.
Mein Team.
Das hängt natürlich ganz klar mit Hinterseher zusammen, der da tatsächlich schon 18 Tore gemacht hat. Wenn der jetzt tatsächlich geht, was man ja so in den Gerüchten hört, da müsste dann schon ein Nachschub kommen. Aber Bochum ist auf jeden Fall eines der Teams, bei denen ich sagen würde, da muss man ein Auge drauf haben, auch für die nächste Saison. Wenn da gute Leute nachrücken, dann kann da schon was passieren.
Und wie wäre jetzt so deine Ferndiagnose, was hat das mit dem Verein VfL Bochum gemacht, dass man jetzt so wie einige andere auch in der 2. Liga einfach schon so lange in dieser 2. Liga spielt und auch schon so lange relativ unspektakulär? Kommen dann nur noch die härtesten der harten Fans? Was macht das mit einem Verein?
Das kann ich dir tatsächlich nicht sagen, weil bei uns aus St. Pauli ist halt immer was los. Entweder Abstiegskampf oder Aufstiegswunsch. Also da ist tatsächlich immer so, dass irgendwas passiert. Das ist mit Sicherheit bei allen anderen 2. Ligisten auch so. Ich habe gesagt, letzte Saison war es noch spannend bis zum Ende eigentlich für fast jeden Verein, außer die, die schon aufgestiegen waren. Dass es tatsächlich so ist, wie momentan, dass es an einem gesichertes Mittelfeld geht, das ist relativ selten in der 2. Liga. Also da ist schon auf jeden Fall immer was los. Was das mit einem macht, so lange in der 2. Liga zu spielen, ich glaube, man stumpft so ein bisschen ab. Das tut vielen Leuten auch ganz gut, weil mir persönlich ist schon aufgefallen, dass bei den um mich herumstehenden, die gucken dann mittwochs, Barcelona gegen Liverpool, und freitags wundern sie sich im Stadion, warum dann die Pässe, die sie am Mittwoch gesehen haben in der Champions League im Halbfinale, warum die am Millernton nicht funktionieren. Also es ist manchmal schon ganz gut, wenn man dann auch mal ein bisschen länger…
Erdungskabel quasi, was dann die Zuschauer am Boden hält, die lange 2. Liga-Zugehörigkeit.
Ja genau. Und ja, was Bochum war ja, wenn ich mich recht im Sinne der 90er war, haben sie sich so ein bisschen zur Grauen Maus in der 1. Liga aufgeschwungen. Das ist jetzt in der 2. Liga so ein bisschen so. Aber trotzdem, wie ich finde, immer noch eins der schönsten Stadien in Deutschland. Deswegen möchte ich gerne mit denen weiter eine Liga teilen.
Das glaube ich dir. Das ist auch ganz interessant, wenn man sich mal die Zuschauerschnitte in der 2. Liga anguckt. Dann drohen über allen natürlich die beiden abgestiegenen Erstligisten. Dann schon der FC St. Pauli mit fast 30.000, Dynamo Dresden, Union Berlin, Magdeburg sind den Nächsten. Dann kommen auf Platz 7 und auf Platz 8 die Bielefelder, über die wir gesprochen haben, der VfL Bochum, über den wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben. Es ist nicht so, dass eine lange Zweitligazugehörigkeit damit verbunden wäre, dass dann auch immer weniger kommen. Sondern der Kern, der da ins Stadion geht, der liegt beim VfL Bochum. Jetzt Schnitt sind 17.000. Das ist locker die obere Hälfte der 2. Ligatabelle. Da liegen ganz andere Mannschaften hinten mit Ingolstadt fast 9.000 und Sandhausen fast 7.000 im Schnitt. Das ist dann ein anderer Schnack. Wir schauen mal weiter in der Zweitligatabelle und dann wartet da schon Greuther Fürth. Die habe ich ein bisschen besser im Blick, weil ich ja gebürtiger Franke bin, mittelfranke sogar. Das heißt, die Fedder habe ich schon häufiger erlebt und konnte ehrlich gesagt mich immer nie so genau entscheiden, welcher Verein sich jetzt tollpatschiger verhalten hat. Der Klub und der Fürth, oft haben sie sich da nicht so viel genommen. Ehrlich gesagt, auch wenn man das natürlich – also hätte ich das jetzt in meiner Heimat gesagt, hätte ich jetzt keine Zunge mehr. Wie siehst du es denn aus dem hohen Norden? Was ist das für ein Verein? Mit 38 Punkten ist man jetzt im Grunde auch durch. Also hat es auch in dieser Saison irgendwie wieder geschafft, aktuell Tabell in Platz 12, die Klasse zu halten?
Also für mich war Greuther Fürth schon immer der Verein, der – es war ja eine Zeit lang Greuther Fünf einfach, weil sie immer Platz Fünf belegt haben in der Liga. Dann sind sie irgendwann mal aufgestiegen und dann haben sie diesen Nimbus des Platz Fünf, haben sie im Grunde verloren. Die schaffen es trotzdem immer wieder, also aus meiner Sicht so eine absolute No-Name-Truppe zusammenzusetzen und damit irgendwie ganz gut im Zweitliga-Fußball zu spielen. Am Anfang der Saison sind sie relativ gut gestartet auch, waren da oben drin, haben da mitgemischt, hatten dann im Verlauf der Saison eine fürchterliche Phase. Ich glaube, da haben sie sechs oder sieben Spiele, kein einziges Tor geschossen und nur auf den Deckel bekommen. Dann den Trainer gewechselt, den alten Trainer von Ingolstadt, den Leitzel, haben sie sich dann geholt und damit haben sie sich so ein bisschen stabilisiert, aber ja, Gräuder führt. Ich werde zum ersten Mal jetzt zum Ende der Saison am letzten Spieltag, werde ich dann mal das Stadion von denen besuchen und dann werde ich mir mal ein genaueres Bild von denen machen, aber tatsächlich laufen die diese Saison so ein bisschen unter den Radar, dann spätestens nachdem sie sich so ein bisschen aus den Aufstiegsringen, aus den Rängen da oben sich so ein bisschen verabschiedet haben, dann sind die so ein bisschen, naja, wieder unten nach oben zu finden und dann wird es für jemanden, der kein Franke ist, vielleicht auch schnell ein bisschen.
Ja und diese Phase mit diesen hohen Niederlagen, die war auch wirklich schmerzhaft, also die ging, wenn man so will, eigentlich schon am 13. Spieltag los, 0-4 bei Union Berlin, dann hat man aber zu Hause nochmal gewonnen, aber dann zum Ende, also es folgte der kälteste Dezember seit ganz langem in Fürth, 0-4 gegen den FC, 0-5 gegen Aue, 0-2 gegen St. Pauli, ein 0-0 in Sandhausen, das war dann das Weihnachtsgeschenk am 21. Dezember und dann hoffst du ja, dass die gute Vorbereitung dann für die Rückrunde eine Besserung verspricht und dann spielst du 0-1, 0-1 zu Hause gegen den FC Ingolstadt, der damals auf Tabellenplatz 18 lag, und dann 0-6 in Paderborn. Also das war die Phase, die du angesprochen hast. Da gab es dann, wenn ich mich jetzt auch richtig erinnere, dann auch den Tränerewechsel und danach wurde es dann etwas stabiler, aber ohne eben zu glänzen. Also da hast du mal ein 1-0 gegen Duisburg, ein 2-0 bei Regensburg, ein 2-1 gegen Darmstadt und ansonsten aber ganz viel 0-0, 0-1, 1-1, ja, Kräuter-Viert eben. Es kann nicht alles spektakel sein.
Genau.
Grüße an Jakob, falls er das hört. No bad feelings, hoffentlich für keinen, der hier gerade anwesend in diesem Podcast. Damit sind wir auf Tabellenplatz 12 angelangt, der ja mit acht Punkten Vorsprung schon so gut wie durch ist. Es sind noch neun Punkte zu vergeben, kann man sich sehr leicht ausrechnen. Jetzt kommen wir mit Erzgebirge Aue auf Tabellenplatz 13 in eine Region, wo es zwar sehr gut aussieht, mit sechs Punkten Vorsprung, aber Aue hatte eine krasse Saison hinter sich. Das sieht man allein schon, wenn man sich anschaut, wie sind die letzten sechs Spiele verlaufen. Vier Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden und jetzt hat man eben nochmal gewonnen. Drei zu zwei gegen Bochum, für die es um nichts mehr ging in dieser Partie. Und das war ein ganz wichtiger Dreier für Aue.
Ja, ein ganz wichtiger Dreier haben die auch am Millernton geholt. Jetzt zum Start der Rückrunde. Das war dann wahrscheinlich der letzte Dreier, den sie davor geholt hatten. Aue ist ein tolles Team. Ich habe lange Zeit. Ist immer noch ein sehr unangenehmer Gegner. Aber die haben tatsächlich, und man glaubt es nicht, da wird richtig Fußball gespielt bei denen. Und dann bauen tatsächlich unter Daniel Meyer, bauen die tatsächlich flach hinten auf. Egal, das Risiko, das nehmen die in Kauf. Und die spielen da meist mit einer Dreierkette. Oder allgemein sind sie unter Meyer relativ flexibel, was Aufstellung betrifft. Da haben wir aber auch häufiger eine Dreierkette dabei. Da sind dann tatsächlich so richtige Fußballer dahinten drin. Also der Wiedra, der Österreicher, der da spielt in der Innenverteidigung, das ist schon einer, der kann richtig gut das Spiel eröffnen. Und da hat sich viel getan, also da ist mit der Mut auf jeden Fall, na ja mit dem Klassenerhalt, drei Spieltage vor Schluss schon belohnt. Das sieht ja in vielen Jahren anders aus.
Absolut. Es war übrigens nicht der letzte Dreier gegen St. Pauli, sondern das war damals der grandiose Auftakt zu einer ganz wichtigen Serie. Da hat man dann nämlich in vier Spielen zusammen mit dem St. Pauli-Spiel als Auftakt drei Siege und einen Unentschieden geholt. Dann kam noch mal eine Durstphase und die wurde jetzt eben durch dieses 1 zu 1 beim HSV und dann im 3 zu 2 zu Hause beendet. Kannst du noch ein bisschen was zu deinen Eindrücken sagen? Hebt sich Aue mit diesem Fußball, also dass man da flach rauskombiniert? Ist es jetzt eine Entwicklung, die auch generell du der Liga attestieren würdest? Wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen letztes Jahr, dieser fürchterliche Fehler-Vermeidungs-Fußball, ja in der ersten Liga auch. Also das war ja nicht zum Aushalten. Jetzt, ich habe das Gefühl, in diesem Jahr, weiß nicht woran es liegt, aber irgendwie ist auf einmal wieder Frühling spielerisch in beiden Ligen. Steht da Aue jetzt exemplarisch für oder würdest du sagen, die heben sich dann schon auch nochmal ab aus dem Segment, aus Vereinen, mit denen sie halt konkurrieren wirtschaftlich?
Also die heben sich schon ein bisschen ab, aber vielleicht heben sie sich, vielleicht ist das nur der besondere Eindruck, den ich habe, weil sie sich so sehr von dem Aue der letzten Jahre, ja fast Jahrzehnte abheben. Es kann auch einfach sein, dass mir das besonders auffällt, dass Aue angefangen hat, auch gepflegten Kurzpass zu spielen, weil sie das in den letzten Jahren einfach überhaupt nicht getan haben und einfach eher so Regensburg-like dahergekommen sind. Aber allgemein hatten wir vorhin schon das Thema, der Trend ist, geht auf jeden Fall dahin, dass man versucht, Fußball zu spielen. Der Trend ist aber auch, dass man auch ein weit höheres Pressing inzwischen spielt. Das ist ja tatsächlich immer, man muss ja fast sagen, das ist dann immer so ein bisschen zeitversetzt, was in der ersten Liga passiert, was in der zweiten Liga kommt. Aber Aue steht auf jeden Fall exemplarisch dafür, dass mehr Fußball gespielt wird. Das ist vor allem für ein Team, was eigentlich ja unten drin steht und was eigentlich als Ziel auch nichts anderes als den Klassenhalt ausgibt. Ist das schon besonders, dass jemand dann den Nut hat und dafür auch belohnt wird, was ich ja super finde, dass man dann Fußball spielen will.
Und es ist auch noch alles vorhanden. Also Aue haut auch schon mal ganz gerne dazwischen zwei und 80 gelbe Karten und drei Platzverweise in dieser Saison. Also es ist nicht nur der flache Aufbau. Sagen wir einfach mal, das sind viele taktische Faus, viele kluge taktische Faus. Da bin ich jetzt nicht tief genug drin, um das zu beurteilen. Aber das ist nach 31 Spieltagen schon auch eine Hausnummer. 82 gelbe Karten. Duisburg kann das noch toppen mit 85 gelben Karten und drei Platzverweise. Ingolstadt 7 Platzverweise. Also da ist auch in der Hinsicht was geboten in der 2. Liga, aber in welcher Liga auch nicht. Womit wir als letztes Team noch zu einer Mannschaft kommen, zu der du ein besonderes Verhältnis haben dürftest. Nicht nur, weil natürlich die Fanszenen zwischen dem FC St. Pauli und Dynamo Dresden sich das eine oder andere Scher Mütze schon geliefert haben, sondern weil das jetzt auch tatsächlich die nächste Partie des FC St. Pauli ist. Und da tut sich ja gerade einiges bei Dynamo Dresden, zum Beispiel auf der Torhüterposition. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du das schon mitbekommen hast.
Ja, ich habe jetzt gerade mitbekommen, dass der Schubart auch nicht mehr aufgestellt wird. Das ist natürlich – also als Außenstehender kann man eigentlich nur die Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen, weil ich persönlich – vielleicht mit Sicherheit werden mir da einige Dynamo-Anhänger widersprechen – aber ich persönlich würde denken, jeder Fußballer, der die Möglichkeit hat, in die erste Liga zu wechseln, dem würde ich ja erstmal sagen, mach es auf jeden Fall. Und klar ist das wahnsinnig ärgerlich für einen Verein, wenn man da im Jugendbereich viel aufgebaut hat und das dann tatsächlich so geht. Ich persönlich finde dann auch, dass die Enttäuschung da auch von Vereinsseite sehr klar dann rübergekommen ist und da wurde dann auch nicht viel Erfolg in der neuen Saison gewünscht, sondern die Rückendeckung war eher nicht vorhanden und es wurde eher gesagt, wie enttäuscht man darüber ist, dass man geht. Ich bin dann natürlich auch nicht hinter den Kulissen und weiß natürlich auch nicht genau, was da dann alles vorgefallen ist, aber das ist schon krass.
Also kurz für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die nicht genau wissen, worum es geht. Es geht um den Stammtäuter Markus Schubert. Dem wurde ein Angebot zur Vertragsverlängerung vorgelegt. Da hat er aber die Frist verstreichen lassen und den Verein darüber informiert, dass er ein Angebot aus der ersten Liga annehmen wird, also im nächsten Jahr nicht mehr für Dynamo spielen wird. Und daraufhin sah er sich solchen Anfeindungen der eigenen Fans ausgesetzt, dass Christian Fiel jetzt in der Pressekonferenz vor dem Spiel gegen FC St. Pauli gesagt hat, dass er ihn zu seinem eigenen Schutz nicht mehr aufstellen werde. Das ist quasi die Geschichte.
Ja, das ist schon recht heftig. Ich muss natürlich dazu sagen, wir bei St. Pauli haben einen Fall, der zumindest ein bisschen ähnlich aussieht. Jeremy Dutzjak hat seinen Vertrag auch nicht verlängern wollen auf St. Pauli, ist jetzt allerdings auch zum HSV zur nächsten Saison wiedergehen. Also das ist vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen was anderes. Aber da hat er sich jetzt in der Fernszene auch nicht unbedingt Freunde gemacht, wobei ich dann natürlich einfach denke, ja dann bin er tatsächlich der Meinung, er ist beim HSV besser aufgehoben und auch der Meinung ist, dass man von St. Pauli direkt zum HSV wechseln könne, dann hat er sowieso nicht verstanden, worum es geht, zumindest bei St. Pauli dann nicht und dann soll er auch gehen. Wie genau die Gemengelage bei Dresden dann ist, wie viele treue Schwüre der Schubert schon getätigt hat, das weiß ich natürlich nicht, ist aber schon ein krasser Vorfall, finde ich persönlich, dass man dann jemanden nicht aufstellt zu seinem eigenen Schutz vor den eigenen Fans.
Gut, das wird natürlich auch ein sehr emotionsgeladenes Spiel, aber da würde ich bei der Bewertung von außen betrachtet schon auch mitgehen, es wird, wenn man näher dran ist, bestimmt ganz, ganz viele Zusatzgeschichten noch zu diesem reinen Fakt geben. Was aber ja auch so ein bisschen stellvertretend für eine sehr wilde Saison bei Dynamo steht. Also man ging in die Saison bis Ende August mit Uwe Neuhaus, haben wir vorhin ganz kurz gestreift, dann durfte Christian Färl schon mal für ein Interimsspiel ran. Dann kam Mike Walpurgis für 20 Spiele und der wurde jetzt wieder beurlaubt. Und jetzt ist Christian Färl erstmal als Fixer-Trainer im Amt. Und das spiegelt sich in einem Saisonverlauf von Dresden wieder, der auch dann nicht so ganz überrascht. Es ging nämlich nie so wirklich gut voran und vor allem die Tendenz hinten raus hat dann doch deutlich nach unten gezeigt. Da gab es ganz lange Phasen mit nur einem Sieg oder vielleicht mal hier ein Pünktchen und ganz, ganz viele Niederlagen. Woran hakt es denn jetzt aus sportlicher Sicht bei Dynamo?
Also aus sportlicher Sicht würde ich das viel an dem Stürmerfest machen, an Kone, der tatsächlich jetzt in der Rückrunde nicht mehr so eine große Rolle spielt. Der hat in der Hinrunde durch, ich würde mal sagen individuelle Qualität viel rausgeholt. Wobei Dynamo Dresden auch eigentlich einen sehr guten Ball gespielt hat. Immer sehr schön mit Aosmann und Artig. Immer sehr schön da im Mittelfeld schöne Überladung der Außen kreieren konnte. Und Kone hat sich da auch immer gerne mit reinfallen lassen. Das sah auf jeden Fall sehr gefällig aus. Grundsätzlich hatte ich den Eindruck, dass dieser Trainerwechsel der erste von Neuhaus zu Vipurgis überfällig war. Das war ja zum Ende der letzten Saison so, dass der Sportdirektor Ralf Minge krank geschrieben war wegen Burnout. Und man hat das dann so ein bisschen aus der Fernszene gehört, dass man den Eindruck hatte, dass wenn er fit gewesen wäre, dann wäre dieser Wechsel wohl im Sommer passiert. Das war so das, was ich aufgeschnappt hatte. Da spielt das mit Sicherheit ein bisschen rein. Dementsprechend ist da natürlich mit Sicherheit ein bisschen Unruhe drin. Und da war allgemein auch im Präsidium einiges an Unruhe. Da haben sich dann auch einige Leute gerne mal widersprochen. Und da war auf jeden Fall – sowas spielt sich natürlich auch immer dann auf die Mannschaft zurück. Und man muss ja nur mal an die obere Tabelle gucken und dabei im Köln und HSV reinschauen, was da los ist, wenn da im Präsidium sich gezopft wird. Das könnte man wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut sich angucken, wie Teams spielen, bei denen sich im Präsidium gerade richtig zopft. Das hat natürlich einen Einfluss auf die Mannschaft. Und ich glaube, dass bei Dresden die Erwartungen sehr viel höher waren vor der Saison, gerade nachdem man in der letzten Saison gar nicht so schlecht dabei war und eigentlich jetzt auch schon gehobener Zweitligist ist, der finanziell ja tatsächlich auch eigentlich auf gesunden Beinen steht oder zumindest beihältnismäßig gesunden im Vergleich zu dem, was man die Jahre vorhatte. Und ich glaube, da hinkt man so den eigenen Ansprüchen so ein bisschen hinterher. Und deswegen ist das so eine sehr ungesunde Gemengelage, die da entstanden ist.
Ja, also man hat so ein bisschen die erste Möglichkeit zum Trainerwechsel gleich gezogen, nachdem man gestartet ist noch 1 zu 0 zu Hause gegen Duisburg, das war noch okay. Dann ging Bielefeld verloren, in Rödinghausen ausgeschieden in der ersten Runde. Das war die erste Runde des DFB-Bukals nach Verlängerung. Und dann hat man eben direkt diesen Trainerwechsel vorgenommen, hin zu Mike Walpurgis, der uns ja auch noch vom FC Ingolstadt zum Beispiel bekannt sein dürfte. Aber die Rückrunde von Dynamo, ganz, ganz fürchterlich. Tabellenplatz 17 in der Rückrundentabelle, nur 14 Punkte geholt. Dass man jetzt überhaupt mit diesen 36 Punkten vermutlich nicht mehr unten reinrutschen wird. Wobei ich ein ganz kleines Fragezeichen da schon noch setzen würde, auch wenn es nur noch neun auszuspielende Punkte sind. Das ist dann eher dem geschuldet, was man dann irgendwie auch unter Christian Fiell jetzt noch hinbekommen hat. Aber da waren einige ganz, ganz schmerzhafte Spiele mit dabei. Nicht nur das 1 zu 8 beim 1. FC Köln. Das werden vielleicht die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen auch mitbekommen haben in der nicht-faschigen Karnevalzeit. So nennt es ganz Deutschland aus der Bayern Karneval war das. Sondern auch es gab ein ganz, ganz unangenehmes 3 zu 4 zu Hause gegen Aminia Bielefeld zum Beispiel. Also auch der Heim-Nimbus, den Dynamo ja nicht nur wegen des hohen Zuschauerschnitts, sondern auch wegen der Art und Weise des Supports so ein bisschen umgibt. Der war in dieser Saison nicht immer so zu sehen, wie man es vielleicht erwartet hätte in der Heim-Tabelle. Auch nur 5 Siege, 5 Unentschieden, 5 Niederlagen. Das ist dann doch nicht ganz so gut. Abschließend, was erwartest du dir jetzt von diesem Duell am nächsten Spieltag? Es geht ja vor allem für Dynamo noch um was.
Ja, also ich denke, der FC St. Pauli würde auf jeden Fall auch noch da noch mal zumindest ein bisschen Druck ausüben auf die Teams. Mit dem Sieg ist man dann ja tatsächlich auch bis auf 2 Punkte ran an den Relegationsplatz. Und die anderen Teams müssen dann auch erst mal spielen und gewinnen. Und dadurch, dass der HSV noch gegen Paderborn spielt, ist da vielleicht tatsächlich noch auch was möglich. Aber dafür müssen aus meiner Sicht – aus St. Pauli sehe ich es sozusagen – müssen alle drei verbliebenen Spieler gewonnen werden. Da hat man jetzt mit Dresden, Bochum und Fürth hat man da drei Teams, für die es dann ja fast um nichts mehr geht. Bei Dresden möchte ich das so ein bisschen in Klammern setzen. Das wird auf jeden Fall – jetzt benutze ich das Wort schon wieder, aber es passt zu gut aufgrund der Gemengelage. Was da bei Dresden gerade los ist, wie es auch beim FC St. Pauli gerade läuft, dass man jetzt gerade wieder gewonnen hat und noch so eine leichte Chance hat. Und dann natürlich auch die innige Freundschaft der Fanszene und dann auf dem Freitagabend. Das wird schon dafür sorgen, dass es da hoch hergeben wird, morgen in Dresden.
Davon würde ich auch ausgehen. Jetzt haben wir den Tabellenkeller in der Folge ausgespart, aber kurz um das Bild zu zeichnen. Also Sandhausen auf Tabellenplatz 15, vier Punkte Vorsprung vor Magdeburg, mit 30 Punkten vor Ingolstadt, mit 29 Punkten, die diese unglaubliche Serie aus drei Siegen und einem Unentschieden aus den letzten vier Spielen gestartet haben. Duisburg hinten mit 25 Punkten, entschuldigung, mit 5 Punkten dann schon so gut wie weg. Und das Restprogramm der Teams da unten ist euch durchaus noch interessant. Denn wenn irgendjemand da die Befreiung schafft, dann spuckt er jemanden oben in der Tabelle in die Suppe. Also für Sandhausen geht es jetzt noch gegen Heidenheim, Bielefeld und Regensburg. Das ist das unspektakulärste Restprogramm. Magdeburg spielt jetzt zweimal auswärts. Bochum, Union Berlin und dann zu Hause gegen den, dann vermutlich schon aufgestiegenen 1. FC Köln. Und der FC Ingolstadt tritt jetzt dann auswärts beim HSV an, spielt dann zu Hause gegen Darmstadt 98 und dann in Heidenheim. Aber dieses Auswärtsspiel von Ingolstadt in Hamburg, das könnte auch nicht unbedingt ein fußballerischer Leckerbissen werden. Aber ergebnistechnisch wird das in die eine oder andere Richtung sehr, sehr spannend werden. Da kann man sich, glaube ich, drauf freuen.
Genau. Ich denke, dass der HSV auch am letzten Spiel da noch Duisburg vor der Brust hat. Also da könnte auch noch was gehen, wenn Duisburg dann tatsächlich auch bis dahin noch eine Restchance besitzt.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, von Duisburg, glaube ich, habe ich in dieser Saison nie etwas Überzeugendes gesehen. Deswegen ja, ich habe die jetzt gedanklich rausgenommen. Du hast aber völlig recht. Fünf Punkte, da ist natürlich auch für Duisburg noch was drin. Das heißt, sie müssten jetzt noch einmal gewinnen in Kiel oder zu Hause gegen Heidenheim und dann käme es im letzten Spiel beim HSV noch auf etwas an. Also der HSV, ein knüppelhartes Rechtsprogramm mit Ingolstadt zu Hause, Paderborn auswärts und Duisburg zu Hause. Da wird noch was passieren und wir werden es hier im Rasenfunk begleiten. Auch dank toller Gäste wie eben Tim vom Millernton bei twitter.ed. Tim unterstrich exdeen mit eck wie das eck und dann STEEN wie Nordpol. Tim, ich danke dir ganz herzlich, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Hat große Spaß gemacht. Ich danke dir. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war der Zweitligakurzpass für diese Woche. Ich hoffe, jetzt sind auch all diejenigen Fans auf ihre Kosten gekommen, die wir in der letzten Woche noch nicht zufriedenstellen konnten. Wir gucken mal, wie das weitergeht. Lasst uns gerne Feedback da, wie ihr diese Zweitligakurzpässe findet. Auch in der Art und Weise, wie sie jetzt stattfinden. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in einer der kommenden Rasenfunk-Ausgaben. Bis dahin habt eine gute Zeit.